david bradford is the eugene o'kelly ii
senior lecturer emeritus in leadership
at the gsb
where he helped develop interpersonal
dynamics aka
touchy-feely as well as much of the
school's leadership curriculum carol
robin was the dorothy j
king lecturer and leadership and
director of the arbuckle leadership
fellows program at the gsc
before co-founding leaders in tech which
brings the principles and process
of touchy-feely to executives in silicon
valley
david and carol taught interpersonal
skills to mba candidates for a combined
75 years in their legendary stanford
graduate school of business course
interpersonal dynamics aka touchy feely
and have coached and consulted to
hundreds of executives for decades
without further ado here are david and
carol
what we're hoping to do here today is
give you a little
refresher and uh tell you a little bit
about what's in our book
and then open it up to questions so
david why don't you take it away and
talk a little bit more about
how we think about the course so so the
book is
our attempt to take the material from
tashi feely and make it available to the
general
public so let me do my view of what the
course is about
we'll see if it has any resemblance to
what you experienced
it's based on the notion that other
people
hold crucial information about us that
we need in order to be effective
and that we often don't get so for
example we're all intentional animals
i intend to be clear i'm perfectly clear
to me
i intend to be helpful i don't know if
i'm helpful
so we act in certain ways that have an
effect but does it have any effect that
i want
or does it have a negative effect that i
didn't want that i didn't
plan for also we often hold a series of
assumptions
about relationships about other people
that can help us but can also hinder us
so if we hold the assumption that uh if
i disagree you won't like me
that's going to inhibit what i say if i
hold the assumption
that if i express anger
uh that is something that you can't
handle
i think most people can't handle it the
third thing is
all of us want to be accepted
and approved of so we tend to act in
certain ways
and to what extent in what we act
we stop being ourselves we present up uh
we give a presented image
and i think a lot of that occurs from
the gsb with a lot of
that occurs in real life so in a sense
other people have information about
the impact of our behavior the phrase we
use in the course
is it takes two to no one i need you
in order to know me i'm an expert on
what i intend
we both see my behavior but you know the
impact of my behavior
and this reminds me of robert byrne's
poem he said the woods of gifty
the gods would give us to see ourselves
as others see us
but often in quote real life
that sort of information is done in ways
that's hurtful it's been out of anger
or is distorted and we still don't get a
good picture of ourselves
and one of the exciting things about
this course and why
in a sense i've spent my much of my
professional career
working on it is that it gives
people the competencies to start to
build relationships
where they can get this information
and therefore can become more themselves
they can they see somebody frown and
they now know how to ask hey what's
going on
and being able to hear it i think one of
the very gratifying things i find the
course
are the number of times in the tea group
a person a student has said to another
one you know when we took finance
together
i really didn't like you you seem to
sort of be showing off
but as i've really gotten to know you i
really sort of like to
and what we find is that when one is
oneself
in an appropriate way usually our
ability to influence
to lead to be impactful
to be approved of goes up so this
course is really about the skills the
competencies
to build those sort of relationships
where i can be myself
and where i can learn about myself and
that's why
students frequently in the course say
this has been transformational
this has been life-changing and we hear
things which confirm this poll that we
just did
we regularly get emails from
alumni 10 20 years out who say
um i'm still using this course
it uh resolved a major issue with my
boss
even i've heard people say it saved my
marriage
it helped me come back from a conflict
so our our issue our problem
was how do we take an experiential
course
it was so powerful and how do we put it
in a book form
and we're going to try and cover some of
the major parts
of the course and the book and to
explore that in greater detail
so carol thank you yes so let me start
by
stopping the share since we're not going
to have a new
uh a new slide for a little while and
then you can
see us a little bit more even though i
know you can make your screen bigger and
smaller
and um let me start by saying that when
as david just said we were faced with
quite a challenge in trying to figure
out how to deliver
what we knew the course delivered uh
in a book since you know as you all know
you don't learn how to be more
interpersonally effective
by reading about it you learn to be more
effective by actually
engaging with other people and finding
out whether or not you are
effective so what we ended up
having to do
we need somebody to mute
thank you um so what we ended up doing
was trying to
first get really clear on
what was it that happened in touchy
theory
uh that so many students you know
learned and then found transformative
and the first thing we concluded was
that what students learn in the course
of the
of the quarter is that relationships
exist on a continuum
and at one end of the continuum there's
contact without any real connection
and at the other end of the continuum is
something that david and i came to call
exceptional which is why that's part of
the title of the book
and you can't get too exceptional unless
you first
get too functional and robust
and sometimes that's good enough so
we're not suggesting that
every relationship in your life has to
be exceptional that would be exhausting
and unrealistic
but we are suggesting as you've learned
in touchy-feely
that you can take most of your
relationships certainly to functional
and robust and some if you're armed with
these skills and competencies
all the way to exceptional if that's
what you both want
so then we got to thinking so so what
are the characteristics
of an exceptional relationship and as we
develop these which i'm going to now
share with you
we realize that you know as you get to a
better and better relationship you have
more and more of these uh so
the first one is that you are
more you feel freer to be more yourself
you don't feel the need to spin your
image
you're uh you're willing to let the
other person really know you
and uh and and many students
and now from for in my case a lot of the
executives that are in my
leaders in tech program find that
incredibly freeing
because as david just said i think that
i need to keep some part of myself
hidden
in order to be influential or effective
and then i come to find out
that actually in sharing that part of me
you find me more influential or you like
me more
you all recognize that if you took the
course
so the second characteristic
of an exceptional relationship well the
the the corollary to that of course is
that the other person also feels they
can be themselves so
it's um it's both of you feel you can be
yourselves more the second
characteristic which goes very much with
the first one is that you both are
willing to be vulnerable
and so i think a lot of the mental model
shift that happens for students in
touchy feely
is that they often think of
vulnerability as weakness
and they come to experience being
willing to be vulnerable
as strength a third characteristic
is that you trust that whatever you do
disclose that your self-disclosures
won't be used against you and part of
the
magic for a while our working title was
the magic of exceptional relationships
because we do think that there's
something kind of magical with touchy
feel
and some of that magic is that
we come to learn that we can trust
and that trust is reciprocal um
another characteristic is that you could
be honest with each other
and and eve even if what you're going to
say might
initially be difficult for the other
person to hear
a fifth characteristic is that you learn
to deal with conflict productively
rather than avoiding it running away
from it
or getting locked in it you learn how to
deal with it
in a productive way and the last one is
that you're
both committed to each other's and your
own
growth and development and that's also
part of the magic
so um you know to talk a little bit more
about what all that
translates into uh you know david's
gonna talk a little bit about
risk yeah all of these are
crucial characteristics and all of them
have risks
which is why we are cautious about it
and why we need
10 weeks to have people experiment with
it
so taking the first one being myself
well i
it's not a matter of sharing everything
we have to be judicious
and the whole notion there's some things
i could share about myself that you may
not approve of
or you may only approve of once you know
me better and can see the whole
background
so it's a risk to share myself it's also
a risk to encourage
other people to share themselves yes
i may want to initially know that you
may have had a troubled childhood
but do i really want to hear all the
details and all that you went through
maybe if we get a stronger relationship
i do but do i want to at this point
honesty well um there's honesty and
there's honesty
and we're all very careful about what we
say to other people
because we know it can be hurtful we can
know it should be taken the wrong way
the whole notion of raising conflict
raising disagreements
we're going to try and show that can
start to build relationships
but it could also damage or even destroy
relationships
so there's risks in doing all of this
and part of what we have to learn is
what do i share at this point in our
relationship
and can i share more but these are risks
that we want to acknowledge and we don't
want to blithely say
oh just share everything raise
everything
tell the truth everything um they
institutionalize people who do that and
we don't want to get you into that sort
of trouble
now that said there are also risks
in not saying by not raising issues and
in not telling
people about you because hopefully one
of the things those of you who took the
class
learned is that in the absence of data
people make stuff up about you
if they don't understand why you're
doing something or who you are
or what's important to you then they
human beings like to make sense so they
make they
fill in the blanks the more you the more
you keep things to yourself the more
they will fill in the blanks
probably with stuff that you don't want
them to fill the blanks in with
uh you know the closer you hold your
cards to your chest
the closer they're going to hold their
cards to theirs and by the way we call
that progressive impoverishment
and then nobody's getting to know
anybody better and more and more stories
are being made up
about each other which never leads to
functional robust relationships
so we do have to proactively take some
risks
and they can be removed in a moment
we'll talk a little bit about how
in a way to kind of minimize just how
much risk you've taken
and you can lessen the probability that
you're going to have a catastrophe on
your hand
because you shared something or the
other person did
and you're also as you take these risks
you learn to repair whatever has
happened as a result
of taking the risk which is another
thing that builds relationship
and builds this more robust way in which
you can interact so um
you know david why don't you talk a
little bit about the
the risk of letting oneself be known
yeah as i've
mentioned uh there's a risk in legend we
known as carol said there's a risk in
not letting ourselves be known so so how
are we going to
handle that um well
there's a couple of things one is what
is it about me
that i want to share and often when we
talk about that
students think well gee something as i
sort of phrase it
immoral uh illegal or fattening that i
did in the past so we get into
storytelling
and what we soon find is that
storytelling can be sort of interesting
but that's not as personal actually
as sharing my emotions sharing my
feelings
so it's not accidental this course is
called touchy feeling
because the emphasis is on the feeling
because emotions are very very powerful
i want to talk a minute about why that's
the case
one thing emotions
give meaning to thoughts so
um one of the things that i do is i tend
to interrupt people
and i interrupt carol well carol
interrupts me
and that's fine because we both value it
because we see it as a lie
as a sign of engagement i had a
colleague
at uh daniel and uh i noticed one time i
was talking to him he frowned
i said daniel what's going on he said
you interrupted me
i said so he said that's
inconsiderate wow
it's not my intention so is interrupting
good or bad a useless question
so it's has its meaning depending on
what emotions we put on
also emotions tell us tell other people
about ourselves it's an important form
of self-disclosure
if you do something that i'm bothered
about
it makes a difference whether i'm saying
hey
hey carol i'm bothered about that or i
say
i'm annoyed or i say i'm angry
or i'm pissed or i'm really furious
those different degrees of emotions
tell tell about me and it tells about
our relationship where it goes in
so we constantly in the course as you've
experienced those have taken it
we constantly are saying to students how
do you feel how do you feel
now that's got learning in and of itself
because in the english language we use i
feel in two
opposite ways one is we use it to
express a thought
and whenever you hear somebody say i
feel that
i feel like i feel as you won't get an
emotion
i feel that you want to dominate the
feelings behind that
but there's not a feeling statement in
that so we constantly say to people when
you
least in the course and hopefully you're
transferring this outside
when you use i feel put an emotion by it
because i can't say i feel like angry
that ain't good english so
when you hear it and the trouble is once
we
are into this carol and i whatever i
hear somebody use i feel and put a that
in it
i sort of want to correct them i try not
to be so annoying
so what we want to say is value your
feeling
your feelings say a lot about you it
says what's important to you
it says a lot about you that others want
to know
now the question is in sharing yourself
how much do you share and students often
say but how much should i share
hang on david do you do you want me to
give them an example of the cost of not
sharing a feeling
sure um because because i
paid a really big cost way before i ever
got to the gsb
those of you who know me know i'm not a
career academic i had lots of careers
before i got to the gsb
and in my very first job i was hired as
the first woman in a non-clerical job
at a large industrial automation company
and
i was this was 1975 so yes i'm old
the dinosaurs weren't roaming the earth
but i'm you know it was a long time ago
i was the only woman and boy did i learn
really quickly that the rules of the
game were
you better leave all feelings and
emotions
in the parking lot and i
i learned that lesson well it served me
exceedingly well
i i went up the ranks in the first 10
years i got promoted and promoted
eventually i was running a 50 million
business and i was at an off site with
my team
who were still all guys i finally fixed
that but it took another couple years
but i'm at the soft site and i'm excited
about something that i think
we should try and i'm getting crickets
and then i get a little more excited and
i get more crickets
and then pretty soon i get really
agitated and one of my guys looks at me
and says
carol is that water in the corner of
your eye
then he says are you gonna cry but then
he says
are you human after all
are you human after all and that's when
i tore up our agenda
and said i don't think there is anything
more important for us to talk about than
that
and we spent the next two days talking
about who we all really were
and there were a lot of feelings
expressed and we realized we had in fact
been leaving half of ourselves in the
parking lot
but that's when we became a team and
that was the day i became a leader
now had i burst down in tears two months
after i was hired
uh probably would have never gotten to
be you know
a manager of a 50 million dollar
business but what what
i think a lot of students learn in touch
philly is that we over learn
something serves us and then we never
experiment with trying something a
little different
which is why david's going to in a
moment talk about how do you start to
expand
outside of what you normally do so
as as you started to say david yeah but
that's a wonderful story i love that
story and i think it makes another point
it's not just that that was
20 30 years ago uh it also
speaks back to the point you said before
that relationships are on a continuum
but they're on a time continuum as well
right so if you were starting that job
today
you also would be careful about how many
feelings you want to show
that's correct and again one of the
important things about building a
relationship
is we can show more of ourselves and
show more of our feelings
yeah and in fact i had created enough
credibility
yes and that you know and i had more
power in the system there were a lot of
things that had happened
over that time so yeah good so carol uh
put up the next slide because i want to
answer the question
students often ask but how how much
should i show
and we say it's the 15
rule so let me diagram that
and we use this this is probably
familiar to many of us
and we say that disclosure i want you to
think in terms of these three concentric
circles
there's that inner circle that zone of
comfort
and that's where we share just about
anything
who we share this to just anybody
you know i've been married for 56 years
i have two kids i have two grandkids
uh yes i've stopped teaching but i'm
doing this i'm doing that
that's how we start conversations often
and start to build a relationship
then there's the second uh circle
which is really the third circle here
i'm gonna get back to the second circle
the blue circle is a zone of learning
and the outer circle is a zone of danger
and that's where you don't want to go
but what we say to students and we say
to our clients
what you ought to do is take a 15
risk and this is a risk and share
something you normally wouldn't share
that's 15 out of your comfort zone
and see what happens usually what
happens
is the other person shares a little bit
more about themselves and that
reciprocity starts to increase and even
if it wasn't quite
appropriate usually nothing disastrous
has occurred
and you can you can recover but
something else occurs as you have shared
this
you find that it gets acceptance and
starts to build a relationship
you start to become more comfortable
with it and your zone of comfort
increases at 15
and then you could take another 15 so
we want to be very clear we're not
saying throw caution to the wind
share everything raise everything the 15
rule applies to much of what we're going
to be talking about next
but it's one way to think about that
progression
progression of being more of yourself
and the progression of building a
relationship
so let's let's give you a moment to just
reflect uh
and i just want to remind you all that
we're going to talk and you know we're
still going to leave
lots of time for q a uh but take a
moment
and reflect on whether or not you've got
a relationship in your life right now
that you'd like to deepen and think for
you know take a 30 seconds 45 seconds
and think about what could you
share about yourself that would let that
person significantly know you better and
it could be
here and now feelings it might very well
be
what's going on for you here and now
rather than deep dark secrets from your
past
so take a take a moment and think about
that
we come back and talk about that more
during q a you might be able to share
with us what
what you're taking away from this little
bitty talk that we're doing
so let me now come back to something
else we talked about at the very
beginning which was this notion of
um one of the characteristics of a
relationship that's moving along this
continuum and is eventually exceptional
is that information isn't used against
you
and by the way all relationships
go through interest through difficulties
some bigger some bigger challenges some
less
but we all unintentionally do things
that that we in the course you might
recall
called pinches somebody does something
it kind of annoys you it kind of bothers
you
and now we're at a choice point so
the question is do i raise it
will you think i'm thin skinned because
i raised it you think i'm good well you
think i'm making a big deal out of it
because i raised it
um or will it help us actually move
along this continuum
and there and it is it's a choice if
it's something that's happened once
you know and it doesn't happen again
well maybe it wasn't worth raising
but if it's something that continues to
happen
my bet is that it goes from a pinch
a little pinch to a bigger pinch and
then pretty soon
it goes from a small annoyance to an
annoyance
and then it gets tied to something else
that the person has done and pretty soon
you've reached what we call
a crunch so one of the things that we
like to recommend
is to raise pinches
and see them as an opportunity to get to
know each other even better
and it's an aspect of learning how to
recover
when something small has gone a little
bit awry
before it's become a big deal
so therefore we want to give you the
second self-reflection
so we're going to put that on and want
you
to think has there been
an incident recently with a friend or
co-worker
where they said or did something it was
a pinch
for you but you didn't share
think about that and then also think
about
why didn't you what were you concerned
but take a minute and reflect on that
okay
and of course what would you suggest you
may want to think of raising it
and see what happens
as an aside i had a student a former
student who wrote to me after she got
the book
and read it and she wrote to me and said
oh my god i'd forgotten all about
pinches
and i realized i had a pinch and i
and i i was like oh oh that's what i
knew that's what i need to do with it
so hopefully part of this is a reminder
for those of you who already know it
but also will lead you to decide to just
up the amount of uh the amount you're
using
what you learned so yes david
okay let's uh let's talk about another
of the dimensions
which is honesty and i want to say that
when i hear somebody say
well i'm going to be brutally honest i
experience them usually more brutal
than honest and they're not honest
because they don't stick with their
reality
so want to talk about what we think is a
core concept in this course
which is a notion that there are three
realities not one reality
and that you get a lot more leverage
you get a lot further if you stick with
your reality
and don't go beyond it so let's let's
diagram that and then i'll explain it
so there's three realities this is what
i started with when i said that other
people hold information on us
one reality is the intent
behind my behavior and all as i said all
of us are intentional animals we do
things for a reason
we do things for to have an effect we do
this all the time
the second reality is my behavior
my words non-verbal tone
gestures even silence is a form of
behavior
that's the only reality you and i know
about me the third reality is the impact
of my behavior on you how does it make
you feel
what sort of emotions come up for how
are you likely to react
what are your responses that's a reality
i don't know but i need to know
so each of us have two of the three
realities
and each of us would like to know the
third reality so in terms of honesty
you're gonna get much further if you
stick with your reality
if what you do is you stay
this is a behavior and this is the
impact on me and that by the way
is indisputable because
that is you reporting on yourself
so i'm going to tell you a story that
happened to me
some time ago where
i was able to say something
that normally one doesn't say
so i was approached by a ceo to do some
consulting in his organization
because he was concerned about how some
of the people were responding
so i went to his company
and um walked in there the reception
finally met him and so on and i'm
usually quite an open person and i i say
often when i what's on my mind and we've
been talking for about 15 or 20 minutes
and job now giving me that name
joe said with some exasperation he said
the trouble with people these days is
um they just walk on eight they hold
back
they don't really say what's going on he
said i really
want to know what was going on and i
reflected for a minute and i was
thinking about
what's happening to me what's going on
within me and um
i said to him i said well joe i
obviously don't know what's going on
in your company but i've got to tell you
that almost from the moment i walked in
the this company the front door but ever
since then i've been
careful about what i was what i'm what i
would say
and i said i usually don't do that i
don't know what's what's happening
so i didn't know what the behavior was
around me i
couldn't yet identify what joe was doing
but i was listening to what was
happening to me on the impact
if i would have said and by the way he
got very leaned back sort of
back and said that's what they say
we then had a productive engagement in
the company
but if i would have not said with it and
if i would have done some guessing
and if i would have said well so your
tone of voice or
well that's behavior i guess but if i
would have made some guess about his
reality
i would have been ushered out the door
so an
image that we like to portray
is that each of us have two antennae
and one on 10 i is what's going on with
me which i was able to tap into
the other antennae is trying to figure
out what's going on
and sensing the other person and
i wasn't picking up much cues so i
couldn't listen to that
so what we want to stress is that
honesty
is going to be more useful if you stick
with the behavior
and if you stick with the impact on you
that in a sense is what i think real
honesty is
honesty isn't attacking the other person
i can say i'm feeling angry
but that's how i'm feeling and that's my
reality
and now let's build on the three
realities and go to the
probably signature model that all of you
who did take the course remember and
certainly a
piece of vocabulary that i suspect
stayed with you
which is the idea that there's this
metaphorical net
between reality number one and reality
number two
and and that's what david was just
talking about when you stick with your
reality you stick with
reality two and three now
let me illustrate this and let me
especially illustrate it with regard to
how we deal with
conflict and how we can give feedback in
ways that are productive which is
another
characteristic of a relationship that's
moving along this continuum
so we're going to go back a lot of years
to when my husband was a big time
executive in the valley
and he would come home after a long
day's work and plop down on the couch
pick up the newspaper i was home with an
infant then a two-year-old
and i'd come zooming around the corner
because i'd heard him come home and i'd
say oh my god you're home thank god
you're home you won't believe what
happened today
and he would look at his newspaper
because in those days we still read
newspapers he would look at his
newspaper and he'd say
and i would say you're not listening
when i
say you're not listening i am over
the net i'm not in his head i don't know
whether he's listening or not
now do you think that makes him more
open to hearing me
of course i'm listening you went to that
new nursery school you're all worked up
about it
now i get even more enraged now
i do more net jumping how can you be so
insensitive
labeling him is really going to ask him
to come into conversation with me
or i'll say something like i feel that
you don't care
remember what david said about feelings
i feel that you don't care is not a few
and in fact it's an attribution and
imputes a motive and that's all
over the net so one of the i think most
important things that students who take
the class or who hopefully will go back
and
read the book or those of you who never
took the class will take away from this
is stay on your side of the net one of
the things that happened once i learned
to do that
is that i would say to andy andy when i
speak to you
and you make no eye contact with me
and the only response i get is a grunt
and then you just repeat what i've just
said with without any eye contact
i don't feel heard that's entirely
on my side of the neck and when i don't
feel heard
i feel hurt and i feel distanced
and when i feel distance i i'm afraid i
won't be there for you in the way that i
want to be
and that takes us into a conversation
that is much more productive because the
point of the purpose of feedback is
to move into a problem-solving
conversation
which david will talk about in a moment
and let me just say one more thing
which is he said
well if you want my undivided attention
you're going to have to give me 30
minutes
to unwind and i said 30 minutes
how about five we settled on 15. so
david
talk about it talk about how feedback
when
on our side of the net helps move this
conversation along
good and what i also want to get a
great story and one i can really
identify with
is that if andy would have retaliated
to those accusations by saying
well you just want uh you just want to
control me
you're so needy you're so needy that
would be another thing
notice he's over her neck
so the net in a sense there's another
net over here
he goes uh over on the other side as
well notice the other thing
is that when carol stuck with her
reality
i feel hurt and he can't say no you
don't
because then he's really over her neck
so feedback that is based on my reaction
is indisputable and also what it does
is it owns the fact and we often say
this that feedback says often as much
about the
giver as it does about the receiver
it may be that carol having two
young kids really was desperately
anxious to have human contact and it
wasn't that andy committed this capital
crime
but that was something that he she
desperately needed
and therefore we we sometimes think well
if i give feedback that's the end of it
as carol just said it starts it then you
could have a conversation
they had a conversation to resolve it
but they also could have had a
conversation about
what does this mean to me and carol
might have said
hey this is why it's so important to me
because i'm home alone
this is what i'm missing and andy could
have said
well you know the sort of day i've had
is so stressful
that i can't handle it to come home to
some stress
then they start to talk back and forth
but they could
best do that if it's not non-accusatory
and therefore we in the book say
and we'll say in class we believe you
can say
almost anything to anybody
if you stick with your reality now we
put the
almost in because we're academics carol
really is too
and if we had two glasses of wine we'd
drop it because we really do believe
if i stick with my reality and if my
intention
is to help our relationship and i'm
willing
to stick in there while we work this out
we could say almost anything to anybody
and and let me just add one more thing
and then want to give you a moment to
reflect
embedded any piece of feedback in the
way we've been talking about it
is a piece of disclosure if i'm going to
include
the impact of your behavior on me
i have disclosed something about me
so we share the vulnerability
a little bit more when we stick with the
model
so with that take a moment and think
about whether you've got any
constructive feedback for
somebody in your life that you feel a
little unsure about
you know how to go about doing and jot
down
if you really want to do this what are
couple behaviors
they're engaging in that are bothering
you got to be behaviorally specific
what are they doing not what you think
they're thinking
how do they make you feel and uh
you know what what gets in your way of
wanting to raise it
so take a few minutes to think about
that and then we'll conclude and open it
up for questions
will give you your homework and just
want to conclude with one observation
in all of this what we want to stress is
you have a choice
you don't have to disclose you don't
have to encourage the other person to
disclose
you don't have to raise an issue you
don't have to share a pin
it's all choices and one of the things
that we stress in the course you
probably remember
is when somebody says i can't we say no
no that's a choice
in fact technically i can't it's a
physical impossibility
i can't jump over this house
but it makes a difference if you think
in interpersonal terms
that everything you do is a choice and
the world changes
if you say i choose not to
or i choose to because that's what gives
you agency
and with agency that allows you to build
the relationships
that you want so take the choices you
want
but own that you have a choice
it's not that you can't
okay let's see what questions we've got
hello there thank you so much so we have
quite a few questions i'm going to start
off
with one regarding how all of this
changes with zoom
about the class itself have you been
able to
uh for the current students taking this
class how has it changed
being over resume if you have that
information uh yes
neither of us are teaching it so this is
the second hand
it's difficult and it's possible they've
had to reduce the group size to eight
from 12
and they find it go slower as you would
expect
but they find much of the same uh
effects
occur maybe not quite to the extent
but uh they've been able to successfully
teach the course
and hopefully this fall it'll be back in
person
i'll also add that i think um not just
in the course
but the minute over the last year it's
become even more important to double
down on what we've been talking about
to double down on because you can't rely
as much on all the
non-verbals you you know i think that
there's it's even more important to
learn to speak
about what we're feeling and uh
and what what the behavior is that we
actually
uh that that struck us because i think
that's harder to do
on zoom what's the next question only
uh so we have a lot of questions about
pinches
yes how if you cannot raise
a pinch at that exact moment how do you
know when the time is right
and how do you deal when you raise a
pinch and it just doesn't go well
well let's start with um
there is no magic answer here oh always
wait
20 minutes so you know and this of
course is the thing that annoyed all of
our students for years which was
the first answer was always it depends
uh
but let's start with the notion that if
i'm doing something that's annoying you
and you don't tell me what am i going to
do
i'm going to keep doing it how would i
know not to do it
and the more i do it the more the chance
is that it's going to turn into a crunch
so how do you know when it starts to
feel like
man it's time to tell carol she's doing
something that's bothering me before it
gets even bigger
as a general heuristic now
you know it doesn't go well let's talk
what does that mean the other i mean i
saw somebody here saying what happens
when they respond with you're just too
sensitive
you know well first of all that's over
the net
uh you know i feel that you're not too
sensitive is over the net
and that's what they're saying i don't
know how to respond to you
is staying on your side in that but the
minute you late
and and of course that's going to make
you defensive
so then you can give them feedback on
what it's like to hear them say that
you know i'm trying to say something
that i think will help us
in a have a better interaction and help
our relationship
and what you just said to me makes me
less inclined to share with you
and therefore i'm worried about where
that leaves us now i'm curious what
david would add to what i just said
no i think that's very good let's get
another question
how do you deal with someone who's not
playing by the same set of rules
you're trying to stay on your side of
the net but they always go over what do
you do
well i think what you do is you
push them back and let me give an
example
let's say somebody were to say to me um
well david uh
the trouble is uh you just want to
dominate well they're over the net
i'm first going to feel a little
defensive and can i hold my
defensiveness
in advance not to say that's bad but i
put aside
and can i push them back and i say
well gee that's not my intention
but clearly i'm doing something reality
number two
that's giving you that feeling
not a they haven't given a feeling but
there's a feeling there it's giving you
that reaction
what am i doing so what i've done
is i have forced them to name the
behavior
and i'm also going to encourage to try
to have a service of feelings
and they may say well they would just
interrupt all the time
and they say well sorry didn't want to
have that impact
uh how does that make you feel that's
usually what i'd say
and they they say well you know i feel
discounted
i feel uh ignored i don't feel valued
and i'm going to apologize i might say
well certainly not what i wanted to do
now that's my tendency what can we do
about it
so i gave the example of my interrupting
carol and
daniel and we had agreed with daniel i
said
daniel i don't want you to feel that i'm
uh being
impolite i'm really going to work hard
enough to erupt but i want you to give
me a little leeway because i know i'm
going to fail
and we're able to work out a
relationship so when somebody's over the
net
you can push them back the other thing
you could also do is you could share
hey when you make that attribution get
defensive makes me feel defensive
it makes it hard for me to want to take
this in
and i without giving him a lecture on
the net i may want to say you know
if you'd stick with the behavior like we
got to
i could have heard it better uh before
you ask the next question
alegria i just see one that i can answer
in like 30 sec
in 20 seconds in the work environment
when there's a reporting relationship
for the more is it is the
recommendations the more senior person
take the first
step at disclosing 15
in building a closer relationship i
rarely am this definitive but the answer
is
yes there is already a power
differential
and if you're expecting the person in
the lower power position
to be the first person to take a risk
then uh you're going to be in many cases
sorely disappointed
so let's take the next question when you
sense
two teammates pinching each other but
not you
how do them start the conversation to
connect
i start with my own reaction
i see the two of you you know having
this
trouble and i'm and it troubles me
and i wonder whether there's anything
that i could do to be helpful to the two
of you
short of becoming the go-between or the
translator
because it's clearly an issue the two of
you have but it's paining
me to see it and uh i might
i might start there how do you repair a
relationship that has had an impasse
and then a falling out and has remained
cold for years
they're speaking specifically about a
family member but
it could also be with a co-worker that
you've just been unable to get along
with ever
i think i would get into my feelings
and uh in a situation like that
in fact one is coming to mind where that
occurred
i was uh feeling a loss of the
relationship
i was feeling sad uh
i was feeling um part of the loss
of longing to go back and
um i took a risk of
first of all finding a time that both of
us were comfortable with and um
talking about observing the behavior g
you know
we don't talk to each other as much as
we did before uh
talk uh that's a behavior
from my point of view uh the talk feels
a little stilted i know i'm a little
stilted
and here's how i'm feeling and i wonder
if i've done
something which has um
caused this chasm between us because i
would like to see
us have a closer relationship like we
had before
so i'm talking about the desired future
now that's a risk
risk in many ways the other person may
want to say
i don't want to see you anymore and i
actually had a colleague who said that
to me
uh well i did i'm still here i didn't
dissolve
or the person may say yeah david you did
something
and am i willing to hear it you see
uh if we open up things
there's always a possibility that
we're partially involved after all
interpersonal relationships
have an interpersonal component but i
don't see that as a fact i see it as a
chance for learning
and i would add that in these kinds of
conversations including
your intent i'm bringing this up because
what i want
what i'm hoping will happen as a result
of us
talking about it is and if in fact your
intent is a good one
you're more likely to invite the other
person into the conversation
uh so i want to make one other comment
based on the chats that i'm reading a
number of you said oh how great would it
be to
get a you know a reminder of this do
this again
uh i'd love to you know so there are a
couple of things that i'd recommend um
one of them is that the gsb
runs a exec ed version of touchy feely
which is an immersion
four day i think i think they've now
started a
two-day weekend thing if you contact me
we offer leaders in tech
four-day immersions as well as well as
a two-day we offer
immersions as well if you contact me
through leaders in tech
and uh and of course there are a lot of
people doing tea groups
that that are in our community so you
contact either one of us
and there are lots of opportunities so
we are actually down to just one minute
but i must ask this question
is there just a moment where a
relationship
has no hope and you just need to give up
on that relationship
i i think the danger there is you blame
the
other person i think i would just say
this doesn't seem to be working it's not
working for me
uh why don't we acknowledge that we had
a pass
and it's neither of our fall and
it's just over and i would urge that you
do that the tendency is to ghost the
other person to disappear
i'm gonna quickly tell a story my wife
had a good friend who lived next door
the friend moved away janet moved away
and
even never heard from her again even
though
janet had a daughter who lived in this
area
and would visit her and evo said i what
if i did something
is it me now we knew that this person
had problems with depression
so it may be due to that but ghosting
people
leaves people in ambiguity and
self-doubt
i think without blaming you be honest
we would like to thank you i think i
could speak for girl if carol that both
of us really enjoyed
it and good luck everybody really
wonderful seeing so many
familiar names and faces and sorry
i couldn't hug you all virtually
yes